will how are you hey gents it's been a
few weeks how you doing we're doing
great how are you doing we're back at
school i see yeah back out of the
parents house i'm doing well all right
so maybe let's just get a sentiment
check before we uh before we jump into
actual data uh how are you feeling in
terms of what you're seeing people
talking about you know publicly versus
uh kind of how you once you synthesize
all this different data we're about to
talk about uh how do you feel
well i personally try to remove the
emotion from it but i do feel like on
twitter or whatever you've seen a lot of
uh you know just general fear or like
anxiety and panic um in the market and
um you know i think
this kind of near-term price action is
has
been provoking that for sure uh but you
know i'm trying to just look at this
from an objective standpoint and you
know just read whatever the data is
telling me so i don't really have any
kind of like emotional
reaction to you know what's going on i
try to just like
ignore that
got it all right so when we get started
here the first thing that uh we've got
is obviously the price uh and a lot of
that is being affected by the perp
futures dominance all the perp uh kind
of uh interest in the market etc
before we jump into the actual data
explain exactly what's going on with
these kind of futures and how that
relates to price in general what can
happen in the futures market that makes
price go up or go down as we as we look
at this data
sure so anyone who follows me on twitter
has probably seen me posting
consistently for the last like two or
three weeks about open interest
and the build up of open interest and so
what open interest is is open interest
is just telling you the amount of
contracts that are open for perpetu for
perpetual swaps
um and so the way to think of this is
these perp contracts are just
essentially bets on bitcoin's price
there's a long side and a short side
and so open interest is just telling you
how many of those contracts are open
and so it's it's kind of a way to gauge
essentially how much pressure is
building up in the pert market but it
doesn't tell you the positioning of
those
um of those contracts or the you know
the market participants on both sides of
the bet so i oftentimes get asked like
when i'll post open interest can you
post
the long open interest or can you post
um the short open interest
and the answer is no and that's because
there's a long and short on both sides
of every single contract so at all times
the amount of longs and shorts is always
50 50 in the perp market there's never
more longs than shorts or more shorts
than longs what you're trying to do is
you're trying to understand what is the
risk that's held by both participants on
both sides of the contract
so for example
you could have like a retail d gen
that's long on one side of the contract
meanwhile on the other side of the
contract on the short side it's a market
maker and so market makers are generally
delta neutral which is a fancy term for
saying that they have no directional
bias right so they they essentially get
paid a fee for for providing liquidity
to different exchanges and so their
their job is to essentially just provide
liquidity and and um allow people to get
fills for their orders and then they get
paid a fee from the exchange for the
amount of volume that their or liquidity
that they're providing to that specific
exchange
um and so you know in that example i
just used right you have the retail guy
on one side and he's just looking to you
know access cheap leverage on the other
end you have a you know market maker who
has no you know
uh directional bias because they're
hedged and that's that's where the
you know delta neutral part comes in
they can hedge either if in this case
i'm saying they're short right um you
know they could hedge by going along in
the spot market and then they have no
directional bias um and so you know that
that
you know the
risk profile of both participants there
is completely different right the person
taking the risk is the retail person on
the wrong side in the in the example i
just described
and so we can get into in a second some
of the things that you can look at to
try to gauge the aggression and the risk
that's held by the different market
participants that are making up the open
interest
but open interest is solely telling you
and by the way you can also look at the
context of the open where you know where
open interest is being opened how it's
interacting with price to also kind of
get a gauge of that
but open interest in itself just saying
that there's high open interest doesn't
mean that it's necessarily bullish or
bearish in itself it's just saying that
you know you're building up the pressure
or in in in my mind that means that you
can expect volatility right because you
have a large amount of leverage that's
built up in the system
okay so when we look at this you had a
tweet on what is this the 4th of january
and you basically were saying if there's
anything i feel confident about in the
intermediate term it's that volatility
is coming to bitcoin and you then later
followed it up with a second tweet that
uh or i'm sorry there's a tweet before
that where you basically i don't know
which direction it's gonna go so i think
you were very much like hey volatility
is coming we're just kind of uh trading
sideways here and that volatility could
go up or down i don't yet have an
opinion on that all i know is that that
volatility is coming so talk us through
a little bit as to like why were you so
convinced that the volatility was coming
which ultimately was a kind of a
downward move in the price but what was
telling you that that volatility was
coming
yeah so first of all like some people
are probably gonna look like you know
listen to this who
are a bit you know less sophisticated
and say well you're just saying you know
price could go up or down like what good
use is that you know first of all like i
think you you know if you don't have an
opinion you don't always need to have an
opinion and so in this case
um i didn't think that some of the clues
from the positioning of the uh
of the of the perps was that clear to me
as to where you know this was going to
kind of resolve um we could talk about
what i think at this current state but
at the you know the time that i put this
out um and the reasoning is because like
for example like the funding setup is
just completely different from for
example summer where you know we were
talking about a massive short squeeze
because funding was you know in a
prolonged regime of negative funding and
was going further negative as price was
grinding above the lows at the time you
know the positioning was pretty clear to
me that okay this is short um you know
lately just because we have just muted
funding i don't think it's been quite as
clear
and so with that being said
it is useful when you
you know when you're expecting
volatility but perhaps don't have some
kind of directional bias because you can
still
um you know make a play on that either
through options or something called move
contracts
on ftx which are essentially bets on
volatility that's why they're called
move contracts
um and so the reason i was just
expecting this was
a we had you know this massive build up
of open interest that hadn't gotten
wiped out at all
especially when you compare open
interest to market cap so this is really
important um this is the in the this
section of these four tweets the one in
the bottom right this is looking at the
amount of open interest in the pert
market relative to market cap and why
that's important is because
you need to get a gauge of how much
weight that open interest has relative
to bitcoin's market cap right because
you could have you know x amount of open
interest but if if market cap is five
times larger than what it is now then it
has a smaller overall impact on the on
the market um you know versus if
you know if the market cap was half the
size it was and we still had the same
amount of open interest then open
interest would have double the you know
effect on the market so
that ratio is a good gauge of you know
how impactful or how influenced the
market is going to be by these uh by the
derivatives
and so in combination with that the
other three charts that i have
are looking at implied volatility and so
this is the volatility that's getting
priced into options
and so the market was pricing in really
low volatility
we were at the lowest implied volatility
since um the end of uh summer so it was
just showing you like people were
expecting you know really low volatility
generally consolidation leads to
expansion expansion leads to volatility
um
and so like
i'm sorry expansion leads to
consolidation but um you know we've been
in this kind of period of consolidation
really tight range between 45 to 52.
meanwhile we've had this massive buildup
of leverage and the options market
hasn't been pricing in that volatility
so
um i was i was looking to take a bet on
volatility i you know like full
transparency i didn't execute on this um
so that's you know like what what good
is analysis if executed poorly right um
so that's kind of a lesson learned from
this for me in terms of i didn't
actually execute on that but um yeah
those are some of the things that i was
looking at and you know perhaps things
that you can apply moving forward um
between the the the dynamics in the
derivatives market as to when you can
potentially expect volatility
okay now after the volatility occurred
and price has gone down uh you began to
share that uh you've personally been
buying uh bitcoin you started to kind of
enter into the market which uh i'm
assuming we can take that as uh you
began to become at least short-term
bullish uh that we had fallen far enough
uh to some degree and i think a lot of
that is this kind of massive macro
support describe a little bit what
you're talking about here um with uh
with these lines across the chart and
why this specific point uh kind of flips
you to being a little bit more bullish
sure so you know it's interesting when
you really zoom out you know throughout
2021 we pretty much just ranged between
30 and 60k
um and so like you know when you kind of
draw this out we have you know the
bottom end of the range is at 30k top
end of the range is at 60k and kind of
this mid line is right around 40.
and so you know last night i posted that
i've started buying because we're down
at this macro support level um which
the reason why you know you always want
to go long in two scenarios either a at
some kind of major support
uh especially if you have you know a
large uh cascade of liquidations in the
bitcoin market or whenever some major
resistance is then flipped into support
um because then you're you're you know
you're showing that the market is
reclaimed strength so since we broke
below 53k
um i've been saying that you know i've
been cautious right until we reclaim
that um what i've been saying is i would
either
look to buy a above 53
meaning that the market has regained
strength
or by in the low 40s um and the
reasoning is because i think that offers
really clear invalidation so whenever
you know whenever you're
taking a position you always want to
have you know validation set for that
idea and saying you know you want to
speak rather than indefinite form and
saying you know bitcoin is going to do
this right you see a lot of people on
twitter saying like
this is going to happen this a terrible
framework to have it you should always
speak in if then format so saying if
this happens right then i believe this
will happen if this happens then my
thesis will change to this um and so in
this case what i've said is if 53 is
reclaimed i'd be looking to go along you
know if we go down to the low 40s i'll
be looking along and then if we you know
if we go below that's my invalidation
for that um and so that's that's that's
why i've started buying some spot here
um just because i think it offers a
really clear validation point as well as
we're at this macro support level um and
so i don't really think there's any uh
level quite as clear from kind of a risk
reward standpoint or you know kind of a
an invalid like a level that has as
clear of invalidation as as 40k up until
like the low 30s um so that's that's why
i've taken a position here as well as um
if you look at like
uh the the chart below we're looking at
the order books essentially just the
heat map of the order books whenever i
post this people are like how do i read
this this looks like the matrix
so i understand like it looks like
there's a lot going on you're just
looking at all the bids and asks that
are active in the order book and then
you're just plotting them out over price
right so you have price and then we have
the lines above are asks meaning
um you know someone's saying
if price reaches this point i'd be
looking to sell right or and then
conversely below we have bids meaning
someone you know someone's saying if
price reaches this that's what i deem
fair value to start you know picking up
some btc
and so what you see is we have this
massive bid side support um on ftx which
is between like 39 to 41 call and those
orders have started to get filled so
i've seen some people being like oh
those are spoof bids meaning like those
are bids that you know once the price
starts going below uh or starts starts
eating into those bids they're just
going to pull them uh but we have
started to see those orders actually
getting filled this is the largest um
you know kind of bid side support that
i've seen since uh the end of july if
you could see kind of in the bottom left
you'll see the this cluster of bids that
kind of set the floor at the end of july
um so like that paired with what we just
talked about from a price structure
standpoint
uh and then lastly just the fact that
we have all this open interest so like
if you go to the if you go to the next
chart uh after the after the order book
after the heat map
um in addition to that you know we have
this massive buildup of open interest
like we talked about
but we've swept the lows now and we
still haven't seen that get wiped out um
and so you know we saw a couple hundred
million dollars liquidations but still i
mean that's nothing compared to how much
oi has been built up over the last month
since that capitulation at the end of
november
um and so to me you know
when
when i said you know i don't think
funding is is giving a clear signal as
to the positioning
of you know the uh
of you know whether it's it's long or
short aggression
i think the the other way you can look
at this is you can say you know how is
the oi interacting with price right
where where has the oi come in so
generally speaking you know when you
have oi coming in um you know as price
is going down that's generally shorts
when oi is coming in on a move up it's
generally people you know
taking leverage longs on the way up
you know it's a very general rule of
thumb it's a bit more nuanced than that
but um you know looking at that context
along with like how is it interacting
with price meaning like
you know if we sweep some kind of major
support level and we lose that you would
expect there to be more liquidations if
if the positioning was aggressive to one
side right so
um
you know i i kept saying like 53 is my
line in the sand we swept right below
that we never got above 53 so we still
don't know if there are a bunch of licks
that are up there or liquidity that's
sitting up there uh to be swept and
potentially you know cause some some
kind of like short squeeze up in that
area we don't know because we didn't
sweep it but we have now swept the lows
and we've we've basically swept down to
the bottom of the the previous wick from
the end of november um and and we're we
are testing to see if there's liquidity
there right we're seeing is that open
interest going to budge and we have seen
you know some some decline in oi but
really really nothing compared to you
know what you would expect right if if
this was you know really aggressive
longs i would have expected to see a
much larger you know capitulation event
and so those factors have caused me to
look to start buying in um and that
doesn't mean that you know i'm like all
in but i have started to scale in a
position here and i haven't in a while
uh because of those factors it's like
you know we're at this again to kind of
summarize we're at this major macro
support
we also have a major bid side from ftx
and also you know it doesn't appear to
me at least
that the that the open interest that
we've built up over the last month
is aggressive longs because we didn't
see more cascading licks i was waiting
really over the last
day or so to to really start um taking a
bit you know to size up a little bit in
in my buying because i was like okay
well let's see you know let's say if it
still gets flushed we've gotten down to
like 41k but you know if if this is all
longs i mean you're talking like a flush
down to the low 30s if this is like
really aggressive longs and we haven't
we haven't seen that
um
and so yeah those are kind of the
factors that have have had me feeling
the way that i that i have been over the
last call you know 12 12 16 hours or so
um you know i i do think that there's
there's a strong likelihood that if we
came back and swept you know that kind
of 53 carrier
53k area um you could see a you know a
much larger wipe out of oi um which
which we just haven't seen on this sweep
to the downside um and so yeah
i mean first of all it's a great
analysis in terms of understanding
exactly what the potentials are uh and
then also what we have validated and
what is still kind of a question mark
right i think which is a key piece to
really understanding this you also have
a chart uh the binance btc usd perp uh
what is this showing us um on on this
specific chart
yeah so
um in the chart above the futures open
interest leverage ratio is what i said
it was comparing the perp open interest
to the market cap of bitcoin this chart
is just um looking at binance
specifically uh the stablecoin margin
contracts um and so we've talked about
the difference between
the collateral being used for different
uh
for
for perp contracts in the sense of like
what's called the convexity uh which is
just a fancy term for saying like if you
are long with bitcoin
and the trade starts to go against you
not only is your p l decreasing but also
the value of your collateral is
decreasing and so the likelihood of you
um you know being
squeezed out of your position or like a
long squeeze occurring if there's a
large amount of those contracts built up
is higher right so like the risk for
downside potential is higher
with stable coin margin contracts it's
it's the opposite uh meaning that like
if the trade if you're short with stable
coin you know with with stable coin as
your collateral if the trade starts to
go against you and you have bitcoin
usually you have like this inadvertent
hedge so like you know
your penile's decreasing because you're
short obviously but your bitcoin as
collateral is increasing in value
because bitcoin's increasing in value so
you kind of have this like inadvertent
hedge right versus if you're margin with
uh if you're collateralized with stable
coins you don't have that hedge so
you're more likely to be short squeezed
um and so generally speaking um you know
it's it's
more favorable for shorts to use stable
coins uh as collateral because think
about it if you're betting on the price
going down why would you collateralize
the contract with something that you
thought was going to go down right it
doesn't doesn't make any sense and
conversely if you were long you would
want to collateralize yourself with
bitcoin right because you know then your
collateral is increasing in value and
tandem with you know the trade that
you're making in a bet that the price is
going to go up so you're basically
betting that your collateral you're
using is going to go up in value
um
and so like this is something that we've
seen as well like going back over summer
we had a large buildup of stable coin
margin contracts while at the same time
uh coin margin contracts or bitcoin
margin contracts um when i say coin i
just mean general overall crypto because
you can do like cross margin where
you're you know you can like on ftx for
example you can margin a bitcoin long
with east collateral or with like
dogecoin collateral right but um but
generally it's mostly bitcoin but you
know to to
the like the correct way to say it's
just like you know coin or crypto
margins um you know whenever that's flat
in stablecoin stablecoin uh
stablecoin oi is higher generally that's
showing you that you know people aren't
feeling at least super confident um with
for for more bitcoin upside because of
the the dynamics we just spoke about
and this is something we saw you know
over summer as well and something that
we've we've seen over the last month or
so uh stable coin margin contracts on
binance had been at all-time highs
actually for the last call two weeks or
so
um and as i mentioned talking about kind
of
how how i've kind of been uh surprised
with the fact that we haven't seen more
liquidations and this is like when i
posted i said um
you know what is this a liquidation a
liquidation cascade for ants that's what
i'm saying i was honestly surprised we
didn't see more licks um you know you'll
see like we've the red in the top right
so like on the bottom half the on the
bottom half of the chart that's showing
you the stable coin market contracts in
the top right you'll see like as prices
decline like we've left out a tiny bit
of oi right like it's but when you look
at the amount that we've built up over
the last month i mean it's like
minuscule right and so um you know that
i'm it's just it's just showing you the
another visualization of like the whole
uh you know set of dynamics that i
rambled on about for the last 10 minutes
okay no well first of all you're not
rambling you're educating people second
is with supply shock ratios next what's
this showing
sure so first of all like you know
you'll notice that um everything that
i've talked about so far and lately that
i've been talking about on twitter like
i haven't really been talking about
unchained much
uh and so the reason is because twofold
um a you know i still do and as i've
said for a long time i see entrepreneurs
the macro of bitcoin so the kind of
broader you know dynamics of what's
going on in the market and it's not
going to give you any signal as to
what's going on in the next couple days
whatever um in addition to that
um whenever open interest is built up so
high
as we talked about by looking at for
example the open interest to market cap
ratio right we're saying that the by
definition we're saying that the
derivatives the derivatives market has a
much higher impact on the overall
bitcoin market structure
um and so
part of the reason why i've been
focusing so much on the derivatives data
is because of that because while we have
such a large buildup of oi that's the
most important data that you could be
looking at um you know obviously like
you know we've had a strong correlation
to like risk off and like traditional
finance and um you know the fed talking
about they're going to raise rates maybe
like march or something like that i mean
that's obviously all important i'm not
saying that's important at all or like
you know the 10-year treasury is mooning
like that that stuff is all very
important but like i'm not going to sit
here and larp to you and say that like
i'm a macro economics expert right i'm
i'm
i specialize in looking at bitcoin stuff
so like i'm not going to sit up here and
start lecturing you on like you know
macro economics and all that from like
slowly a bitcoin perspective the most
important data that i think you can be
looking at right now is the uh
derivatives data or at least the most
important data that you could have been
looking at over the last month or so
um and so with that preface from just an
on-chain perspective um the supply
dynamics that we've been talking about
still do look healthy like we have this
massive bull div from an on chain slowly
on chain perspective between call at the
end of november until now like you'll
see the liquid supply shock ratio has
just been ticking up and up and up and
up um very similar to what we saw over
summer where we had a bullish divergence
and very similar as well to what we saw
at the end of september where we again
had a bullish divergence there um this
this one's actually larger than both of
those um and so what that's what that is
showing you is that like
supply is moving to
entities that have a low
tendency to sell so liquid entities are
entities that take in and holds over 75
percent of the coins they take in or the
op the other way to think about it is
they only sell less than 25 of the coins
they take in so generally speaking these
entities are the strong hands in the
market from an unchained perspective
and so we've seen supply continue to
move to these entities uh you've also
seen a slowdown in spending from
long-term holders the net the net
position change of long-term holders has
actually flipped green over the last
couple days now this is definitely
important but it's obviously not taking
into account the other side of the
equation which is demand
and so what this is really telling you
is that
the the way i like to analogize this is
like the fuel
meaning the supply dynamics the fuel is
laid out for a major rally right meaning
that
excuse me the float of bitcoin is very
low right the the amount of available
bitcoin to be bought is very low
but that doesn't tell you about the
demand and so
um this is why
this is why the
uh the liquid supply shock ratio is is
impacted it's more impactful when it's
declining that it's increasing and i
know that may seem a little strange but
what i mean by that is if you think
about it from first principles whenever
this is declining what it's showing you
is that supply that was previously held
by what were perceived to be strong
hands statistically speaking
you know
they then became weak hands and so you
have supply that was previously locked
up that's now coming on to the market
and so those are those are um you know
those are uh forced you know those are
not for sales but those are cells onto
the market right so that that's
immediate having an immediate term
impact on the market because those are
market sells versus when you have you
know supply that's slowly getting locked
up it's showing you that it's getting
locked up right it's it's it's the float
is getting dried up but that's not
necessarily telling you that the demand
is stepping in and so what what this is
basically saying is like
if you know it was like again talking if
then if then format
if if you start that c demand step in
because of where the liquid supply shock
ratio is you could see an aggressive
rally to the upside right because the
float is so low the available amount of
bitcoin to be bought is so low but that
doesn't necessarily mean that bitcoin's
going to rally in the next week or so
just because supply is getting locked up
because you're you're not accounting for
that demand side so that's that's the
kind of like nuanced view of it there um
and like
i don't i don't think this is the case
but this is like kind of the devil's
advocate just because my job as an
analyst is always to present both sides
to every you know to the argument um i
think this is the smaller probability
side of of the two but the devil's
advocate argument would be if all the
supply is locked up
meaning people are most likely ex
locking up supply expecting higher
bitcoin prices um you know
if if you know you continue to not see
upside right if we continue to just have
this like slow grind down do you start
to see some of these entities that have
been locking up supply in anticipate in
anticipation of higher prices um you
know do you start to see them get antsy
and start to you know move out of their
positions
i you know it's obviously possible but
you know by definition this metric is
showing you the spinning behavior so
like statistically speaking these
entities hold at least 75 percent of the
coins that they take in so that that you
know the odds of that are low because
there's their literal statistic you know
spending behavior is very low but that's
not to say that like you know that that
devil's advocate argument is like
impossible to play out it's just i don't
i think it's on the very low spectrum
because of you know we're actually
looking at like what is the likelihood
that they will do that which is less
than 25 so
and the last chart that we have here is
the on-chain cost basis what about that
yeah um so this is what like had me
initially cautious is
whenever we broke below this like if you
look at this historically this is served
as kind of support in the bull market as
well as resistance in the bear uh so
like especially once we break below and
then confirm from the underside
that's when you know that's when you can
uh you know kind of have this bearish
bias as well as you know whenever we
break above and then confirm you know
from the from the above side you know
when we confirm this as support that's
when you can like really start to
to you know have a more bullish bias in
the market
uh recently we broke below that's when i
got cautious in that kind of red circle
on the upper right hand side of the
screen and recently it does look like we
had kind of this failed underside
re-test um so it's definitely something
to you know keep in mind um for you know
as i talked about earlier there's two
there's two people you know there's two
types of buyers
in terms of trading obviously there's
people that dca into bitcoin every day i
do as well i have a you know trading
stack and a long-term holding stack um
for traders you know you either want to
buy
support right
especially if we have in the bitcoin
market you know some kind of like
cascading liquidation events almost
always a good idea to buy you know some
kind of
for selling event especially just
expecting like some mean reversion so
you're either looking to buy support or
you're looking to buy
when previous high time frame meaning
like you know broader um you know uh
like kind of more more macro not just
like you know talking about like hourly
candles like broader time frame
resistance flipping into support or or
getting reclaimed uh and so that for for
me from an unchained perspective is the
short-term holder cost basis so you know
as i said i've started to scale in some
buys not fully but i've started to scale
in some bias here at this macro support
level for all the reasons that we talked
about earlier
for the people that are a bit more
conservative and may say hey i'm going
to wait and for for the market to show
me strength
um you know those type of buyers i think
this is a good level that you can look
at to kind of uh get a proxy for once
that momentum has been reclaimed in my
mind if we can reclaim the short term
holder cost basis then we've kind of
reclaimed momentum um so like my kind of
middle framework is like
there's there's generally value buyers
and momentum buyers in bitcoin right
because there's no cash flows for
bitcoin and a way to value it people
coming into bitcoin are either buying it
because you know it's really strong
momentum or because they think it's like
extremely discounted um
and for whatever reason you know that
the difficult paul did the pull the
differ difficult part is identifying
you know what is what is your definition
of momentum what is your definition of
value
um and so to me the low 40s feel like a
nice value zone um but from a momentum
perspective
um you know the 53k feels like that area
where we would reclaim momentum and so
for you know people who are kind of like
these like more high time frame swing
traders
what i think is kind of the sweet spot
is buying when we come out of a value
zone and are then reclaiming momentum if
that makes sense so you're coming out of
an area of that's identified as value
and then you're now you know reclaiming
what what appears to you as high time
free momentum in the market for me that
would be that 53k level um
so like yeah for the for those type of
buyers that are looking to get back in
the market once like high time frame
resistance flipped into sport that's
that's kind of that area that i would
personally be eyeing
joe john what questions you guys got
well what's going on man good to see you
uh yo my question would just be around
like the retail traders so there's
obviously a large sum of people who are
just uh dca into this they're they're
more retail oriented they have a long
time horizon they just believe in the
asset in general right so watching this
uh obviously some of them are probably
getting nervous right seeing the price
decline and they don't really understand
the fundamentals but they know that
they're going to be in it regardless
maybe they go buy some more or whatever
it is but are there like one to two or
a few charts or metrics they should be
looking at your mind that are like the
most obvious hey these are just things
you should pay attention to outside of
price that can make them a little more
convicted or more worried on the other
side of it
sure i mean i think first of all like
the data is definitely supporting what
you're saying um you know when you look
at like
the holdings of retail so this is like
something i've seen a couple like
analysts talk about and like
um kind of as the the
argument against what i'm about to say
is that like retail is accumulating like
retail is always accumulating when you
look at on chain like that really
doesn't have much signal like the rate
of accumulation you could you could
argue that that does
so like for what i mean by that is like
retail accumulates more so their
holdings increase more in a bull market
which makes total sense right because
like number go talk number go up
technology is like the biggest form of
marketing for bitcoin but generally
speaking like that chart goes up and to
the right um so i don't really
personally find that like super useful
but i do think like retail exuberance
has definitely subsided uh so this is
like something i've talked about with
like ralpal and he's been seeing some
similar stuff in the data he's looking
at as well like one one big uh like one
big basket of metrics that i've been
looking at is like the
portion of volume that's
being taken up by retail uh and so what
we can see is like since since kind of
april to may it's interesting like a lot
of like peak transactional activity
actually happened on that dip down below
um
when we initially like
i'm trying to think how to describe this
like we moved down to like i think it
was like 47k we came up to like 52 or 53
and then we moved down to like 30 uh
in like the in the middle of may like on
that dip to 47 before the major
capitulation like the last big dip
before the major drawdown in summer
that's where you saw a lot of like the
peak of transactional activity
interesting enough like you would think
it would be on like april 14th like at
the pico top actually wasn't um that's
when you saw all that kind of like
retail exuberance um you know kind of
kind of peek out
and like the percentage of volume that
they've taken up kind of pick out um
and then since then you've seen that
decrease along with the amount of uh the
amount of overall transactional volume
that's um that's that's you know consume
the market has been taken up by like
much larger entities so transactions
that are like you know
a million to 10 million or 10 million
dollars plus so
like i guess what i'm saying is like
kind of the the big boys are are running
the show in that sense now and a lot of
the retail exuberance has kind of been
wiped out people that just come in for
the number go up technology when it's
only going up and have no conviction at
all so like that definitely is true um
for the people that maybe are getting
shaky i mean i would just say like you
know you need to listen to more podcasts
or like read the bitcoin standard and um
maybe you also need to reduce your
position sizing like if if your position
sizing is keeping you up late at night
then maybe you need to cut some of that
like you should be you know you should
have enough bitcoin and your your your
educational level is definitely gonna
definitely gonna you know
aid how how comfortable this allocation
is but you know
you could go all the way from the
spectrum of being like ray dalio right
who has like a two percent allocation
which is essentially just like a hedge
against the fiat system all the way up
to some like the hardcore bitcoin guys
who are maybe like 90 90
95 bitcoin pomp i don't know if you're
still up in that allocation i know you
were at one point but um
yeah like you know it it depends on that
so like i would say you know there are
some like on-chain data points you can
look at like hash rate or like user
growth over time going up into the right
and like obviously that's like insanely
bullish for long-term network growth or
like the lightning network growing and
that being like the
second layer being built on top of
bitcoin to help it transition to a
medium of exchange but really i think it
just comes down to like education
educating yourself on like what bitcoin
is like if you're questioning yourself
because of a price drawdown do you
really under like fundamentally
understand like what's going on with
bitcoin like you know this is like one
of the most volatile assets in the world
it draws down you know
50 to 80
pretty regularly throughout its history
like have the fundamentals changed for
bitcoin no it's just you know the the
price has changed um and so like you
know those are the times when ideally
you want to be like if you're just like
a dollar cost you know averaging uh
long-term investor those are times when
you probably want to start like
averaging in more once it's you know
kind of below like historically you know
where you kind of deem you know fair
value for bitcoin um for the people that
like are losing conviction i would yeah
i'll just say like
educate yourself more whether that's
like reading books like the bitcoin
standard or like um
you know some of these other like
articles that are out on on uh like the
bullish case for bitcoin
uh by vj and or you know and in general
just like podcasts i think the best
content there's like a whole side
conversation but the best content for
bitcoin is like the podcast like pomp's
or peter mccormick's which is the second
best bitcoin podcast my podcast got to
show that and then you know a couple you
know like you got like the stefan lever
i mean there's all different kinds of
bitcoin education that's completely free
out there for you to consume i mean like
hundreds and hundreds of hours so i
would say like you combat your loss of
conviction with educating yourself about
what bitcoin is and if it really comes
down to it maybe you just need to reduce
your position sizing because if you've
taken one dollar and put it into bitcoin
over any five year period that's so
let's say you've had a hundred dollars
you put one dollar into bitcoin kept the
other 99 in cash over any five year
period that one dollar that's in bitcoin
is outpace the 99 in cash so it's like
you know
even even having a small position i
think it's still sufficient in terms of
protecting your purchasing power and
like you know you need to kind of find
whatever you know kind of happy medium
that is for you for me being 19 i can
take a lot more risk right because i
could lose it all and and i can i have
enough time to make it back right versus
you know maybe some like my grandpa
right who's like 85 i'm not going to
tell him to go 90 in bitcoin right he
only needs a you know 10 15 allocation
because he just needs to hedge his his
spending power and preserve that so you
know it depends on the person but yeah
again like
just educating yourself uh as well as
like adjusting that position size
joe those are all great points and you
just started your podcast you're already
top three in bitcoin podcast so congrats
um how do you think about the difference
and like the psychological aspect of the
hype and the momentum versus like the
macro environment with rates and other
stocks
no i mean it's totally a factor and
especially because like
we we've been talking for a long time
about oh the institutions are coming
institutions are coming so hype about
the institutions um and you know kind of
the like devil's advocate to that is
like you know when you have like macro
drawdowns or you know whenever there's
macro uncertainty you're gonna see
bitcoin sell off that's the trade-off
that you're making by you know wanting
to have institutions in the market so
bad uh everyone was expecting
institutions and you know like you know
willingly like you know saying so myself
like the beginning of last year i was
definitely in this camp as well i was
like well institutions are going to come
in we're going to see more corporate
treasury announcements and they're
probably gonna look to have you know a
5-10 year time horizon
well in fact i think what we actually
saw was just like more active managers
that saw bitcoin kind of as this like
macro trade uh against the monetary
debasement of last year and so with that
being said now that you've seen
uncertainty about monetary tightening
you've seen a lot of those same entities
de-risking their bitcoin position um and
so you definitely have seen some kind of
correlation with that um and so
conversely i think like the people who
are buying
are you know longer term like [ __ ] you
know hardcore you know crypto thesis uh
investors who
are looking at this fundamentally as you
know an asset class for the future and
and you're seeing that you know the
you're seeing a transition of of supply
and suzu had a post about this last
night essentially saying like
you're seeing a transition of supply
from these like macro hedge funds or
active managers to people who actually
have this like long-term uh you know
belief in in this you know technology
and the asset class moving forward um
but yeah i mean i definitely think like
over the last month the you know main
driver of price action has been macro
you've seen you know a lot of uh risk
off behavior and equities and uh as well
as you know you've seen like the the
10-year treasury moving right and we've
seen the fed talk about they're going to
do three rate hikes next year uh
probably somewhere around march and so i
think you've seen that getting priced in
for sure um yeah i mean and moving
forward i think it's a question of like
are we going to see that correlation
strengthen or not strengthen um i think
that's a difficult question to answer
but um you know i i would suspect like
if your thesis is like you're gonna see
more institutions come into the market
then your thesis should also be that
you'll see a stronger correlation to
tradify gotcha
well
when you think over let's say the next
week what are your thoughts in terms of
do you expect us sideways up down you
don't know
how do you think about just just the
next
week i mean i think we're set up for
some mean reversion at least in the
short term like i think i'm i'm def um
you know a long time ago when like we
first started doing this i would throw
out like i would you know i i would do
like price price uh you know projections
i'd say like i think price is going to
reach this and like
my thinking about this is as definitely
like changed over time because you know
you just can't account for all these
factors there's so many different
variables and so you kind of have to
take it like level to level and you know
instead of like trying to predict like
what price is going to do you have to
just look at it and you know say for
example like my thought process for
buying here is not necessarily that like
oh bitcoins gonna moon from here it's
just like we're at high time frame
support we've been drawing down for the
last month or so we have a large buildup
of open interest and so like when you
look at like you know where you see the
potential downside versus upside i think
that's skewed to the upside right now
and so that's just kind of how i think
through positioning myself like level
the level rather than like looking at
you know trying to predict like where
exactly is price going to be i think
like almost everyone has kind of learned
from that uh you know this year we've
got like you know
everyone from you know myself for sure
you know willie wu or plan b with the
stock to flow model um you know i think
the trying to trying to look at price
and you know call it the next like six
months or so i think is is really
difficult i think it gets easier if you
say what's going to happen to bitcoin
over the next 10 years i mean everyone
in the space is
uh except for the people that are you
know the weekends that have been getting
wiped out lately you know are here for
kind of the longer term thesis of
bitcoin and i think it's like not you
know it's not controversial to say that
bitcoin's price is going to be you know
higher in the next five to ten years uh
in the next six months i you know trying
to predict like kind of those like
midterm predictions i think it is really
difficult when you have all these
different variables especially now you
know with like macro uncertainty for
example um as well as like all the
different dynamics going on in the
bitcoin market so yeah that'd be my
answer
i think that uh you're on to something
here my friend and uh your level of
level your
your lack of uh wanting to do short-term
price predictions i think is just a sign
of uh of maturity um you don't know i'm
about to do this but i got to bring up
one thing that has nothing to do with
bitcoin but i got it in the mail and so
you know what i don't know oh good
do you know what i do oh yeah she's
she's she's gonna be very
for everyone at home pay attention
i got an envelope in the mail and i
opened the envelope
and i saw this it was my favorite thing
i received in the mail the entire
christmas season because i am now
officially
on the clemente's
christmas card list look do we have a
close-up of the christmas card i think
there you go
this
is what i call perfection you got
everyone in there you got a little bit
of the holiday you got will i mean just
this was perfect and so i got this and
i've had it sitting here on my desk this
exact one this entire time until
now that we've talked about on the show
i'm gonna put it on my refrigerator so
that i can say oh i'm always hanging out
with the clementes
thanks
oh your mother i appreciate my mom will
be hyped the package finally came
through so yeah
um all right now oh people love it
they're like god man people love the uh
love the christmas card maybe we have to
do a best business show christmas card
it's a whole little late for that but
yeah no i mean listen
hey
it's uh always summer in miami it's
always christmas everywhere else it's
fine um all right well what uh what what
did we end the year by the way on uh on
followers we crossed over 500k right
yeah uh
i don't know i think we're like oh five
five thirty so we're getting up there
for the reason all right though i gotta
be honest i didn't expect when you were
saying 500k by the way you were right i
was like i don't know man i guess a lot
but i guess you understand the network
effects of how it grows so
listen i'm not i don't know all the
things but that was uh directionally it
was going to be more than people thought
rather than less and that's what
happened so congratulations will now has
500 000 followers if you don't follow
him on twitter
you're lost you're missing out lost in
the sauce
appreciate your brother we will uh we'll
do this again next friday hopefully uh
we'll uh we'll be talking about prices a
little bit higher but
hey
only thing worse than uh seeing the
price go down is not understanding
what's going on so appreciate you coming
on educating everyone i think that
everyone is uh learning a lot from it
and uh let's go
totally thank you guys and uh
yeah i'll see you out there on twitter
man
all right later yeah well take it easy
guys